hey my net hey Greg those are our names
10 the worst celebrity parents that ever
exist from the richest YouTube channel
I love celebs I want to hear who are
some bad celebrity parents so I can
gossip about it with my friends you know
who's a bad celebrity parent right now
oh I can't even think of any other pop
in my head yeah let's see which ones
were the worst I bet I bet these are
like mistakes these celebrities made
forever ago they're still looked at as
being a horrible parent even though they
might have try their best to prove as a
parent like Alec Baldwin and his
daughter or when Britney Spears had her
kid like driving around her Hummer or
something this is horrible I might cry
really parenting is tough for non
celebrities so when you're rich and
famous parenting is too easy right
here are the worst celebrity parents in
the world
Madonna waah Madonna maybe among royalty
in the world to pop she still has a few
lessons to learn in the world of Paris
damn right when her daughter Lourdes
Lyon was just 6 years old she was
sharing the stage with her famous mom
when she shared that three-way kiss with
Britney Spears and Christina Aguilera
she has also humiliated her son Rocco by
posting photos of him online dressed in
girls clothing and dragging him on her
rebel heart tour all the while
supposedly helping him keep up with his
studies the rest of the Madonna children
have also said their mother resorts to
weird and harsh punishments for little
things like leaving clothes on the floor
JimBob what does she do for a while Jim
Bob and Michelle Duggar were the epitome
of good parenting as shown on their show
at 19 Kids and Counting
and they became celebrities overnight
for popping out so many kids job however
people criticized the Duggars for
leaving their youngest children to be
raised by their older children when it
was realized that Josh Duggar had
molested his younger sisters instead of
being reported to the authorities they
sent him to work for a friend for this
summer and soon accepted him back
after the Josh Duggar scandal their show
was immediately yanked off the air force
dina Lohan yes first time dina Lohan was
known as the worst mother in America she
came her daughter Lindsay was growing up
Dena was taking her to nightclubs long
before she was 21 and facilitated her
daughter in experimenting with alcohol
and her mom doesn't see Lohan started to
show erratic behavior and seemingly lost
her mind
Dena blamed it on the media and
Hollywood after Dena appeared on the dr.
Phil show to tell her story she do like
the house questions and asked to go home
and then flipped off the camera Joe
Jackson I liked her it was widely known
that Joe was pressuring his children to
become famous and even went so far as to
beat Michael as punishment for little
thing heard that Joe was often the one
who is blamed for Michael missing out on
his childhood and why the King of Pop
acted so much like a child Oh
after he died Michael left nothing in
his will for his father but that didn't
stop Joe demanded a $26,000 monthly
payment from his son's estate your mom
in August 2015
Rosie O'Donnell took to social media the
team was eventually found safe but she
had a different take on what actually
happened okay she stated that she was
actually kicked out because her mother
knew she was going to leave when she
turned 18 Chelsea also stated that her
mother had been handling the separation
from Kelly carpenter very well and that
she was smoking pot regularly sleeping
in only doing her makeup if someone else
was doing it and quit her job on the
view because she was afraid of Whoopi
Goldberg races even told Chelsea that
she was born addicted to heroin
but she found out it was untrue after
checking medical records Wow Wow
David Hasselhoff okay David Hasselhoff
seemed to be the picture of a perfect
man with a successful television career
and followers all over the world yeah
however the after he had a dark secret
of substance abuse and didn't hold back
in allowing his children to be exposed
to it all after
hustle house daughters with the video
would be active trying to eat a
cheeseburger while drunk well they're
pretty Joan Crawford Joan Crawford was
among Hollywood royalty in her time she
also adopted five children and seemed to
be living the fairytale life however
after her death in 1977 the daughter
Christina Crawford shocked the world
with her tell-all book Mommy Dearest in
the book she described her mother as a
violent alcoholic who often abused her
children with Christina taking the brunt
of the anger the book was even made into
a movie starring Faye Dunaway as
Crawford Oh
Woody Allen oh [ __ ] well Erin's shocked
the world when he left his wife Mia
Farrow in 1992 what was a bigger shock
was that he left me up for their 21 year
old adopted daughter soon-yi while Allen
was 56 Mia told the press that she had
also found naked photos of their
daughter while going through her
ex-husband's things and wondered just
how long the affair had been Oh almost
20 years Courtney Love didn't learn much
from her late husband's suicide and
turned to drugs for comfort even though
she still had a daughter Frances Bean
Cobain to raise Francis didn't have a
fairytale childhood with love constantly
on drugs drinking and starting fires
from forgotten cigarettes she was 16
Francis filed a restraining order
against our mother stating that she
didn't feel safe with her mom always
being under the influence especially
after the two got into a physical fight
the judge granted the order and Francis
was said to live with her grandparents
Charlie Sheen what really Charlie Sheen
also lost custody of his four children
to Denise Richards and Brooke Mueller
don't even let Sheen near his children
due to the fact that he is seen as a bad
influence with an unstable home life and
inappropriate surroundings Wow
where do we begin with christen people
have a love-hate relationship with the
mother of the infamous Kardashians and
the ex-wife of who we now know as
Caitlyn Jenner kris has often been
criticized for her parenting skills and
using for children to gain money and
fame
looking at how her children turned out
and the criticisms they give to their
own mother it's safe to say that she
shouldn't be writing any parenting books
and each time soon sweet Wow a lot of
fun stuff there a lot of fun stuff there
with Madonna though they kind of I feel
like they're being a little too harsh on
her honestly I think so I mean where was
the daughter in that kiss no she's not
in the kiss she's just in the crowd oh I
see
she's just an entertainer yeah [ __ ]
also I think with all of these people
when you're in that position things get
to your head and then you have kids and
then parenting is hard enough as it is
but when you have all these people
watching you and all their comments and
pressures and it can't be easy like
parents make mistakes
constantly yeah but when a celebrity
gets caught for making a parental
mistake it's like you're the worst
parent ever yeah if my mom was making
out with two women on stage I'd be
confused yeah but not everybody would
know about it yeah not everyone happened
now and then like her posting pictures
of her son and girls having fun like
yeah kids smiling and shits it it says
like their mother resort so weird and
harsh punishments when they leave like
clothes on the floor I want to know what
those punishments are you think she like
does a seductive dance for them Jim Bob
and Michelle Duggar I don't know these
guys you've never heard of the Duggars
no kids and counting that mean there's
more on the way if I'm not mistaken they
literally
said that she's popping out more
children Wow good for her good for her
just first of all have a wife like that
wife you just pop out children wait an
easy-bake oven they're literally like
rabbits
hey 19 kids having one is difficult
enough and a husband named Jim Bob is it
like a Cheaper by the Dozen thing or are
they just all from the same parents this
is almost cheaper by the two dozen Wow
two-for-one deal and then there's son
molested the younger the daughters oh
geez there's no jokes here people know
no jokes here except dina Lohan whoa
crazy party a woman at Lee yeah yeah
she's hot though for like an older like
messed up lady she's pretty but is this
a photo of her kissing Lindsay I think
they're kissing each other oh my god
well is that hot no maybe I was like
involved but now it's the idea of like
them doing that on their own time yeah I
know but like sometimes a mom and
daughter can be really hot but I've
never heard of an actual situation of
that going down I don't know no she said
Lindsey's like absurd behavior was all
media and [ __ ] no it is because of bad
parenting Deena it's probably the media
they got to hurt yeah and then in turn
she has a party attic dude yeah aching
her daughter to clubs in her twin I
didn't realize like whoa no wonder
Lindsay Lohan's like like messed up
these days because her mom's a [ __ ]
freak I should have bite her on the
channel I heard Michael Jackson's dad
was like [ __ ] like nuts I've heard
that too I heard the dad would get
prostitutes in like apartments like
hotels get prostitutes and then he would
have Michael Jackson that's a little
kid read the Bible to them that weird
really yeah it's like a real thing I
heard Wow many the same thing because my
dad never made me do it
fine prostitutes read you know parts of
Harry Potter to them fantasy I didn't
know Rosie O'Donnell had a kid I didn't
kill the Rosie O'Donnell know what she's
done her daughter that was pretty crazy
stuff but like you're a heroin baby and
all that oh my gosh her daughter is like
really pretty I wonder does he like
adopted she like they took the eggs
artificially yeah yeah exactly I
contributed that all the time so I make
my income Rosie O'Donnell though like
maybe because she's a lesbian has
nothing to do with it I don't know it's
like I imagine she'll like just burst
into flames and attach daughters
gorgeous though yeah David Hasselhoff
man Oh God Knight Rider to Baywatch I
don't remember this video of him trying
to eat a cheeseburger while drunk really
was on the news it sounds hilarious oh
my god I was trying to like I kept
missing his mouth or what I guess so oh
poor guy you know like it's tough being
yeah I can imagine it's tough being
famous I really I really do think that
you know I feel we're in their position
I would do it this way you don't know
until you get there yeah exactly when
you have no private life like none and
your private life is exposed to like the
public upon millions
people I can only imagine how horrible
like how I how it's hard to just be in
touch with yourself only to calming life
yeah you probably just constantly live
in fear yeah and trying to escape and
stuff so I get it like I get a
Hasselhoff I forgive you for your sins
Woody Allen though marrying his adopted
daughter a bit weird it's really weird
cuz she's Asian he has an Asian thing
does he well apparently he does I mean
it's crazy they've been together for 20
years
yeah they have children together and
like I mean it sounds like it worked out
better than what he had with the wife I
guess oh you know technically she's not
blood you know yeah you know like I
dated my mom I'm adopted it's a good
time I'm gonna have some good memories
you know to let each other go though but
we still think on all right guys if
you're new to the channel please do me a
favor try to hit the subscribe button
it's a lot of work monette is a lady who
likes to make healthy delicious treats
on the sweet et youtube channel hey
there friend Jess I was recently on
there watch that and follow us on our
Facebook and instagrams and Twitter's
because why not